[Music]  we're talking about three early mornings  and three main roads affected by the  electric daisy carnival it's going to be  the northern 215 beltway then mainly the  i-15 and also las vegas boulevard here's  the dealio  every morning at six saturday sunday but  especially monday morning there will be  thousands if not tens of thousands of  cars leaving the speedway to get onto  the 15 maybe the 215 and also leaving  las vegas boulevard now monday morning  will be much worse than saturday or  sunday morning but anybody traveling in  the area of the las vegas motor speedway  please watch out for cars and  pedestrians as there may be some folks  from the electric daisy carnival trying  to walk somewhere now this is also going  to include those rideshare vehicles as  well but there'll also be buses now  maybe keep your eye to the sky too  because there could be some helicopters  going in and out of the speedway as well  back to you